oh yeah
me too just before I get started on a
Clippers you know I want to thank the
trying to wrap their fans you know I
have social media so I'm not able to put
out a you know paragraph or whatever but
but like I was gonna say
just think of Toronto the city of the
country you know it's a great amazing
season best Parade ever things said that
doctors for you know delivering my baby
my baby boy he's three months now still
healthy also wanted also we'll just when
it on you know think the city as far as
the restaurants you know giving up that
Hawaiian died throughout the playoffs
took advantage of that you know the
players they already know it so you know
takes FaceTime me
we'll talk coaches staff as well and the
whole organization really just thanked
the whole city thank you but now I'm on
my next journey these guys I think we
got a great future Paul is always a
player that I wanted to play with like
you were just saying when I got drafted
to the Pacers of Mike they already got a
you know to lie player pretty much but
uh you know as our careers moved forward
you know I see how he develops the art
develop and I wonder if we would have
stayed in Indiana but you know we're
here together in LA
both Southern Cal guys play right down
the street with each other in a Honda
Center not with each other but game at
there won another championship game I've
been watching them since then but uh you
know now we own the Clippers and it's
just I think we got some special we
could make history here and you know we
got the right team to do it with Steve
Lawrence and dark
championship head coach and I'm excited
you know watching that video that they
just presented already to go
[Applause]